The answer is reject, and you can see it easily from the data shown here.
79.74 is the mean. This is the 95% confidence interval--less than a kilogram.
The reason why it's so small is because we have so many data samples, really interesting.
As a result, we don't even come close to 73.
So, if all the guesses that you guys voiced online were actual measurements
using the actual scale of Sebastian,
and this is what I told you and the question really was H0.
Is Sebastian telling the truth or is he lying?
The, using statistical techniques, you should conclude he's lying.
This is somewhat contrived. This is the only data point, and everything else is just guesses.
But I hope you had fun using actual data that you students derived in answering this question.